5 26 on your wednesday morning now the
ongoing conversation about cars with
expired tanks includes the department of
motor vehicles
our most recent report about viewers
frustration with cars on the road with
expired tags included bob asking how
much money is the state losing from
these scoff laws and diane also asking
about the loss of revenue well thanks
now to the nevada dmv for weighing in
with this tweet
there's no way to track how many
vehicles aren't registered so we can't
provide an estimate of lost revenue the
tweet continues but late motorists do
have to pay all of the back fees late
fees and penalties and the full fees for
the year ahead once they do register
and the dmv also tweeted that they have
sworn officers issuing citations to
improperly registered cars two officers
here in the south one in northern nevada
thanks again to the dmv for weighing in
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone you can join the driving
you crazy conversation at traffic 8
8newsnow.com